and where i like being is
like i i had a guy who used to work for
me alex cherpinoy
uh and he created this beautiful project
called ergo to me that is the spiritual
successor to bitcoin
ergo is really special because it has
the same culture it has the same
mentality
and the technology is kind of like a
natural evolution
of what you would do if you knew about
bitcoin and you wanted to build the next
big thing
so it's still a proof of work system
it's still a utxo system
but he added utxl with some smart
contracts it's this
sigma protocol idea on the proof of work
side satoshi had this one cpu one vote
idea
so alex tried to create
non-outsourceable puzzles to make it
impossible to have mining pools
and there's all these other beautiful
little things and he's just he's this
brilliant
russian programmer and he surrounded
himself with all these other brilliant
people
he has zero ego he's like his negative
ego when you put him with a person with
ego your ego goes down yeah
right and everything about alex is
always like how do i solve this how do i
do that
and he gets legitimately excited when he
meets somebody that
he can collaborate with or learn from
that's where bitcoin was
in the beginning everybody set their
egos aside whether it was hal finney or
whatever
and they would just say how can i help
what can i do and it was all about
coming up with some cool new thing or
solving some cool new problem
i don't see any of that in bitcoin today
so quite a few people are excited about
ergo and excited about the fact that you
kind of appreciate alex and ergo do you
see cardano potentially utilizing
the proof-of-work mechanism from argo as
part of this
uh pool for the consensus mechanism
i mean anything's possible and you know
there's a lot of evolution ergo has to
go through
and ergo was it was kind of like when
the xbox 360 first came out
while they were prototyping it microsoft
needed a development environment they
ironically purchased a lot of
apple computers to do that because apple
was moving away from the power pc to
intel and
microsoft was moving towards the power
pc just this weird intersection of
history so at that time the largest
order of mac computers made was
done by microsoft and they were using it
for xbox stuff so ergo we viewed the
same way
so we said well we have this extended
utxo model the only thing that's as
sufficiently close to it where we can
beta test contracts
is actually with ergo and alex just was
a little faster in getting certain
things out because
we were doing things in a slightly more
rigorous way and slightly more
expressive way
so we actually tested a stable coin and
oracle and other things on ergo
and it has just incredible community
when we said hey we're coming here to
work and built this oh yeah we love work
with you guys this is so cool
uh the other thing is alex used to work
for us and he had this lovely project
called scorex and it was all about
like a pedagogical framework for
building blockchains and if you want to
do prototyping or academic research it
was great
it was super modular and it separated
the consensus network and
transaction layer from each other in
just the right way so
that you can make it modular and mix and
match things so you can secure academia
or maybe a different network layer and a
different
consensus protocol like proof of work to
another proof of work and so forth
so we loved having that kind of ips
sitting around
because it gave us the ability to kind
of play around with ideas in a matter of
weeks
instead of months or years and then he
just took that concept and he gave it
away
the wave protocol was built on it uh
that was uh
sasha ivana he did that and i think
there's two or three other
cryptocurrencies that were launched from
scorex and then
alex took and that and built ergo from
it
so there was a nice intersection where
there was overlapping technology
with ergo with our technology and the
other thing was that the community was
so open and friendly
it was just a no-brainer just go in and
start building some things there
now in terms of evolving ideas the whole
sigma protocol idea is very different
and it's very interesting and
there's a guy at a boston university um
his name will come to me in a segment
who who came up with this stuff and i
think there's some merit there
especially as we start moving closer to
this idea of
blockchains being used to validate
proofs instead of running computation
what's the sigma protocol rather
so it's just a way of expressing scripts
and uh
basically you get these concise
representations of proofs
and then you can say okay the script is
correct but you don't have to run the
whole program
so there's a lot i'm not doing the topic
justice there's a lot more to it but
that that's the basic concept and
in a redeemer validator model you need
stuff like that because as
as your your model gets more complex and
a lot more things happen
it's you don't want to have a situation
where i have to run
replay a huge amount of the utxo graph
to be able to get to a point where i
have the state of the system
you need some mathematical artifact that
gives you the state of the system
quickly and then you say okay i now know
how to what computation threat i need to
run to be able to
get enough to be able to redeem this
transaction so he just found a more
compressed representation of it and you
know
the math doesn't matter what matters is
there's a whole beautiful
field that thinks about this type of
stuff and
it was never once linked before into our
industry
the brilliance of alex was to actually
realize you could do that and pull those
things together
and it may actually have some error but
by no means is the only guy that does
this stuff there's actually
other approaches in verified computing
that have explored that
like my favorite came out of microsoft
research is a project called pinocchio
and there was a follow-up called
geppetto
and the basic idea was that uh it's
fortuitous
that you know you have these computer
science problems like um
hashing where you can
you can do all this computation and once
you've done all of it you found this
magic number that you can verify that
the computation was done correctly
so the proof of work works this way hard
to do the proof of work easy to check
the proof of work
uh cryptography also works this way you
have some trapdoor where you can verify
something's correct but to get
that thing done you know if you're doing
it brute force it takes an enormous
amount of computation
well not all problems are like this like
protein folding to verify the protein is
folded correctly you have to pull the
protein you have to redo the work
but what if for arbitrary computation
you could take a problem
and then you could generate a proof that
you've done that computation correctly
and the proof validates in logarithmic
time or constant time
wow that's incredible right well
microsoft actually wrote a paper on how
to do that it's called pinocchio
so that's another example of these types
of things these roll-ups of things where
instead of doing the computation on
chain or trying to create some sort of
replicated machine that does all this
stuff
you instead just say okay only thing i'm
going to use the blockchain for is to
check your proof
but i'm going to turn it into a
distributed computing problem and any
person in the world can do the problem
on any server untrusted server even
because you you don't have to trust the
output you trust the proof
and the proof is deterministic it tells
you these things
so you know whether you're using zero
knowledge or sigma protocols or you know
some other mechanism it's moving you in
that particular direction
to turn it from a replicated to a
distributed problem and go from i'm
doing the work to i'm checking that the
work was done
that's fascinating and all of a sudden
we're back to the pe equals mp
yeah uh thing where the for many very
interesting problems the checking
is efficient uh is much more efficient
than the solving
right and also do you want complete
determinism or is it probabilistic
because if you relax that requirement a
little bit then suddenly actually
you have a broader class of things you
can construct this stuff for
you